when I was like seven or eight like  seven I think my mom died from my heroin  overdose she was 25.  she had a really messed up childhood so  and then we were in a motel with her at  the time and so like we were there with  her body like me and my brother alone  and the ambulance got there too late  and then after that  um  my brother's dad wanted a custody of him  all of a sudden  I don't know why but just he wanted to  be in the picture all of a sudden and  then so my brother didn't have the  choice to go back like  with who he knew as family which was my  grandma and my dad so when we went to  court they asked me if I wanted to stay  with my brother or go back to my family  so I said